[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAVINDER SINGH: Some of you
may have seen our announcement
with NetApp a few
weeks ago, or you
may have heard this in the
keynote today or yesterday.
We've been working
with NetApp for a while
to build Cloud Volumes for GCP,
which we'll talk about today.
Essentially, the vision is to
build a high performance file
storage offering, a fully
managed service that's
integrated with
GCP, something that
supports multiple protocols,
is very versatile.
You can-- whether you're
using NFS or you're using SMB,
or if you're looking for
something that integrates
with Kubernetes or any of
the GCP managed services,
the idea is to have
one file storage
service that can provide that.
Also if you're used to
advanced management features,
like snapshotting,
replication, cloning,
and you want the same
thing in the cloud,
this is the service
that would provide that.
Also, and what truly makes
this a partnership of firsts,
is if you're a Google
Cloud user, a GCP user,
and you're used to our UI,
or you're used to our billing
or working with Google
support, none of that changes
when you use Cloud
Volumes for GCP.
So essentially, the
idea is to give you
a completely seamless
experience if you're
using Cloud Volumes with
Google Cloud platform,
and you keep using the
tools that you're used
to when you use Google Cloud.
Now, before I go
further, let me quickly
introduce the team that
will be joining me today
into today's session.
So my colleague from
Google, Devin Lehman--
he's been working with
me on this project.
And from NetApp,
we have Alim Karim,
who's the product manager
for Cloud Volumes,
and Jonsi Stefansson,
who's coming
here all the way from Iceland,
leads cloud services in NetApp.
So we're going to keep this
keep this light on slides
and focus more on demos.
Just to give you
a quick overview
of what you can expect
over the next few minutes--
so we will have
Alim talk about why
customers may want to use
this service, some context
around use cases.
We'll talk about what
this service really
is, capabilities of
the service, what's
unique about this service, and
as well as the architecture.
And then we're going
to switch gears.
Jonsi and Devin will come
onstage and do some cool demos
and talk about how do you
create a cloud volume,
or how do you create a
snapshot, and how do you
manage the file service that
you spin up in the cloud.
And then Alim is
going to wrap up
with talking about use cases,
and we'll do a Q&A after that.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Alim
to talk about Cloud Volumes.
ALIM KARIM: Thanks, everyone.
And thanks for, again,
attending an afternoon session.
So let's get right to it.
Again, we want to cover
maybe two or three
slides in the beginning
and really hand it over
to Jonsi, Devin, and myself,
who'll walk through the demo.
So before we get too deep
into the technical stuff, what
we wanted to do was sort
of step back and look
at this from more a
strategic point of view
and really understand
the customer context.
So before we developed Cloud
Volumes, we spent a lot of time
talking to customers
and understanding
the nature of problems as it
related to unstructured data,
files, and public cloud.
And after analyzing all of
those conversations, what
we found was you could basically
categorize these problems
into three main sets, and
each of these three main sets
had a key persona.
So first, you had a set of
application administrators,
application owners that were
trying to move POSIX compliant
applications from
on premise into GCP,
and they were doing these
for a variety of reasons.
Perhaps they were shutting
down a data center.
Perhaps they had a
cloud first strategy.
Perhaps they were trying to
modernize the application,
and the first stage was to
move it to GCP to do that.
Or perhaps they
were supporting--
the application was supporting
a business process that
was variable in
nature, and they wanted
to take advantage of the
elasticity of the cloud
to support that
business process.
So there is a varying,
different things
on why they were
trying to do this,
but the lack of enterprise
grade file services in GCP
essentially left them
with two options.
One, you go through this
massive architecture process
even though there
may not be anything
wrong with the
architecture of your app.
It's risky.
It's complex.
Or you just say simply I'm not
going to move this application.
So we saw a problem there
that could be solved.
The second set of
people and problems
were a set of developers
and DevOps engineers
that were either trying to
build applications that required
shared file semantics
in GCP, or they
were trying to use
workflows that require
persistent storage in GCP.
An example we've seen over the
last year, it come up a lot,
is applications that
are being refactored
to use containerized platforms
and run on GKE requiring
persistent storage.
Cloud volumes is a
good fit for that.
And then, finally, we have a
set of data analysts and data
engineers that have
unstructured data
set on premise that are
trying to take those data
sets to the cloud to actually
extract value out of those data
sets.
What we found common across
all these three problem sets
is the set of
service expectations.
So anything that solved
these problems had
to have these three key things,
and the one that bubbled up
to the top, this
notion of experience,
was pretty much the
paramount thing.
And experience here
has multiple facets.
It's not just about how well
integrated the product is
from a look and feel
perspective into GCP,
but users really wanted
a consistent experience
with Google.
So that means support.
That means billing.
That means operations and a
multitude of other product
related aspects deeply
integrated into GCP,
and that's what we focused on
to bring with Cloud Volumes.
The other two pieces around
consumption and economics
actually go hand-in-hand.
So with the ability
for this thing
being a true cloud service,
they expect consumption
to be able to go up and
down, and the economics
should match that pattern.
So now, let's talk
about Cloud Volumes
for GCP and the various
elements involved.
And again, this is more of
a service overview slide,
and we'll talk about the
technical details here
in a second.
But the simplest way to think
about cloud volumes for GCP
is that they are a simple
to consume performant
NFS or SMB endpoint.
It's a no op service, so
you as an application owner
or as a developer
simply just consume
that NFS or SMB endpoint.
You don't have to
worry about any
of the infrastructure
related tasks
around setting things up,
patching things, maintaining
things, scaling things.
That's handled seamlessly
between NetApp and Google.
You just get the
NFS or SMB endpoint
that you're interested in.
The second thing around native
user experience-- and the demo
will really show you
what we mean by that.
But the engineering teams
have spent a ton of time
integrating this so that
it looks and feels exactly
like any other Google
service to the point where
there's no separate punchouts.
There's no separate UIs.
How you authenticate into
the Google Cloud console
stays consistent as you
move into the service,
so there's a security element
to this integration as well.
And I can describe
it all I want,
but you'll get to
see it firsthand.
So NetApp has had a rich
history in data management
over the last 20
years, and we're
bringing all of that
goodness to Cloud Volumes--
the ability to take
snapshots, the ability
to then create rapid copies
out of these snapshots,
and the ability to
synchronize data.
That's all coming
to Cloud Volumes.
Support is another thing we
hear from customers about a lot.
Oftentimes, when we
talk about new products,
we focus on the beginning.
It's like, what does the
user interface look like,
and how well is that integrated?
But we have to think about the
lifecycle of the product right.
And things will go
wrong, and customers
want to know that there
is an integrated support
system to help them
when things do go wrong.
So with Cloud Volumes
for GCP, support
is actually integrated with
Google in that L-1 support is
offered by Google.
Google always answers
the support call,
and Google always maintains
the customer relationship
with the customer.
They may escalate to
NetApp in the back,
but Google always owns
the customer relationship.
Moving on to some of the
elements on the right-hand
side--
so this is a cloud service.
It offers a true pay-go
consumption model.
It's based on
allocated capacity,
and you can vary the amount
of allocated capacity
over the course of a month.
Billing is integrated
into GCP as well,
so all of that
allocated capacity
that you consume over a month is
billed directly through Google.
You don't get any other separate
invoices or things from NetApp.
Everything happens
through GCP, again,
keeping within that
same ecosystem.
And then, finally, we're going
to enable hybrid enablement
for the service in that we're
going to allow customers
to move data both from on
premise and other SMB or NFS
services into Cloud Volumes.
And then the region
piece-- we're
going to start this
service in US East 4.
We're going to roll out
to other regions in the US
by the end of the year, as
well as some regions in Europe,
and we'll cover that towards
the end of the presentation.
So one thing that is very unique
about Cloud Volumes for GCP
is this notion of
service levels,
and so it bears a few
minutes worth talking about.
So think about Cloud Volumes
coming in three flavors,
and these three flavors
are identical in terms
of the protocols they offer,
as well as the rich data
management features
that they offer.
So across these three
flavors, you get SMB or NFS.
You get snapshots.
You get copies.
You get data synchronization.
How these three
service levels differ
is in the amount of
performance that you
get per allocated
terabyte of capacity.
So the three service
levels are listed here--
standard, premium, and extreme.
In the case of standard,
you get 16 megabytes
per terabyte allocated.
In the case of premium--
64 megabytes per
terabyte allocated.
And in the case of extreme--
128 megabytes per
terabyte allocated.
Why did we do this?
We did this because
customers are
going to use Cloud Volumes
for different use cases.
So if you're doing
virtualized applications,
if you're doing general
purpose databases,
premium is probably
where you want to start.
If you're doing high
performance computing,
if you're doing
genomic analysis,
extreme is where you want to go.
But we also give
you the flexibility
to change these tiers
because oftentimes we
hear from customers-- we kind
of know, but we're not sure.
So start off with
one, and you're
free to change it
to another one.
So before we go into the demo,
just one quick technical slide
on what the building
blocks are and what
this architecture looks like.
So in this case,
on the far side,
we have the Cloud
Volume service.
This is where you provision
and get your volumes from.
On this side, on
the left-hand side,
we actually have a GCP project.
You have a region
in that project.
You have a set of instances
within a given VPC,
and all of those instances
have access to cloud volumes.
And you can control this
access using export policies,
and you'll see this in
the demo in terms of how
we secure these cloud volumes.
The key thing I want
to point out here
is that cloud volumes are a
regionally accessible resource.
So even if you have
compute incidences
in zone one, zone two, zone
three in a given region,
all of those compute instances
can access cloud volumes
in that given region.
So with that, the
engineering guys
told me don't go more
than three or four slides,
so I kept to that limit.
And now I'm going
to bring them on
to actually talk about
the product itself
and give us a demo.
So Jonsi, Devin, please?
JONSI STEFANSSON: Hey, guys.
Hey, everybody.
We actually want this to be
as interactive as possible.
So if you have a question--
we share the feeling
that we hate slides.
And we would always
inevitably say, hey,
you guys are not
doing a live demo.
Of course, we're
Even though it's from a
staging environment, all
the bells and whistles.
So we actually wanted to
be really interactive.
So if you have questions,
just raise your hand.
And we'll stop and answer
all those questions.
Take it away, Devin.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah, we'll start.
So how many are familiar
with the OnTap UI itself?
Have people used that before?
Awesome.
So one of the big things
Alim highlighted early on
is that this is the first
standalone service within GCP
that's going to look like
a third party service, so
everything within Cloud Console.
Your provisioning
volume is going
to be the same thing you're used
to in the NetApp environment.
So we thought, just
to kick things off,
we'd kind of show you discovery
phase within marketplace,
and then go into the
solution and kind of click
around and see what's happening.
So with that, you search NetApp.
Launch solution.
You're going to
have the overview.
It's going to talk-- it's
a NetApp solution running
within Console, the types
of services, when it's
been updated, things like that.
But it brings you right
into the volumes page.
So again, if you're used
to seeing Cloud Volumes,
you're going to notice things
like the name, the region
it's deployed in, life cycle,
the service level, the usage,
and what's reserved
for snapshots.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah,
and you can actually
customize like you can
and everything in GCP.
You can actually customize the
way your task would actually
look like.
If you want to pop up, for
example, who the project
owner is, what the
region it is in,
and the availability or the SLA
tiers that you have actually
selected.
ALIM KARIM: A few
other things to note
here is that that transition
between the marketplace
and this particular view,
as I mentioned earlier,
and you see it, that there's
no other authentication
or punch out that
you have to do.
It's just seamless.
It just goes from the launcher
into this particular UI.
The other thing
to also note here
is that the service level
is in all of the columns,
but the volumes always exist
in the context of a Google
project.
Just like any other Google
resource within a project,
if you have two
separate projects,
it's two separate
sets of volumes.
Volumes in a project always
exist within the context
of a project.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Absolutely.
Yeah, so going through
the creation process,
again, should be similar to
what you're used to in the past.
But click Create a Volume,
choose whether it's NFS or SMB.
Enter your name.
You can see we've
done this a few times.
Choose the volume path and
then choose the service level.
So something that's super
important with this particular
solution itself--
it's subjective to what's
going on in the time of year,
subjective to the
industry you're using.
You can toggle back and
forth between service level
subjective to the performance
you're asking for.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah,
if I can interject.
The service levels--
I mean, you can actually view
the UI as being stateless.
Every single action within
the UI is an API call,
so you can actually
automate that via an API.
And for example, if you're
having seasonal spikes
or you know that the
traffic that is coming in
at 4 o'clock-- you
can actually switch
on the fly between starter,
premium, and extreme.
By doing that, we actually have
a scheduler that actually looks
at, if the controller
is congested,
then it actually moves
and migrates the volume.
So this is something that we
felt like was really, really
important to be able to
meet these unexpected loads,
and you should be able
to do it on the fly.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah, awesome.
Going along same path,
you select the region
which you want to deploy in
if you want to create snapshot
for this particular view.
And then your
allocated capacity--
5 terabytes.
From here, if you're
a GCP user, it's
going to be of a similar
experience as well.
You choose a percentage of
snapshots you'd like visible,
a great slider, and
then we can choose
expert policies,
which is something
Alim talked about earlier.
ALIM KARIM: So this
is really where
you get to secure that volume.
And security, obviously,
in the cloud is important,
but there's multiple
different aspects.
This really controls
who has access
to this particular volume
and how they have access.
So you can actually limit
it to a specific client
by specifying one
IP address, and you
can say that client
has read-only access.
Or you can do side
arranges, saying
these clients within a subnet--
10 clients, 50 clients,
whatever it is--
all have either read-only
or read-write access.
This is how security for
the volume is managed.
DEVIN LEHMAN: And within the
security protocols as well,
we can then choose
a snapshot policy,
so if we want to go hourly,
daily, weekly, monthly.
Easy to use.
Easily consumable within GCP.
So we're going to
see that volume.
It's going to load.
It's going to go back into the
overview, which we were just
looking at before.
ALIM KARIM: And so
typically, at this point,
it's like you've gone through--
you've created a volume.
In this case, we showed
creating an NFS volume.
You create an export policy.
Now it's ready to be consumed.
So the next thing you
want to do is actually
look at how you would mount this
volume inside of your clients
to access it.
DEVIN LEHMAN: So within that,
we've built it in straight
into the UI.
You just choose the toggle
or the hamburger menu
on the right, get
mount instructions,
and you're going to see
the standard calls you
can make from your CLI
or your particular API.
We actually have it
here, where you can just
copy directly and then
fire up your terminal
and mount your volume straight
from the computer you're using.
I think it's just really
great for any particular user
because you don't have to go
between different interfaces,
and again, it's
just drag and drop.
JONSI STEFANSSON: And maybe
show the difference to mount
instructions for SMB as well?
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yep.
There you go.
JONSI STEFANSSON:
So one of the things
that we're actually
going to be introducing
is you can actually
have multiple protocols
on the same volume.
So you can actually service
both Windows and Linux clients
within-- from the same data set.
ALIM KARIM: And this is
something that we've heard
again from customers
about-- is that they have--
basically, treating
these volumes
as a high performance
bus between applications.
Like in health care,
they have applications
that are Unix
based, applications
that are Windows based, and they
need a way to share this data.
So these volumes act
like a common repository
across two very
different architectures
to enable that sharing
of data to happen.
And I'm surprised, we haven't
gotten even one question yet.
Someone must be curious
about something.
Yeah, yes?
AUDIENCE: So with
the SMB integration
and that mixed
integration modelling,
that could get real interesting
on the permissions--
ALIM KARIM: Permissions, yes.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I didn't see
anything in the GUI so far,
but I suppose they could--
JONSI STEFANSSON:
So you can actually
show-- if you go into the
Active Directory connection,
so you actually have to have
your own Active Directory
server running
within the project.
So it has a network--
yeah.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah.
JONSI STEFANSSON: So that's
how you are actually taking
care of--
for example, for NFS v4,
you need Kerberps and LDAP
and all of that.
So that's all taken care of.
In the beginning, we're
only doing NFS v3 and SMB.
When we're introducing
NFS v4, then we--
there will be an
additional top that is
doing the LDAP configuration.
ALIM KARIM: And to answer
your specific question
around security-- so as
Jonsi said, as we introduced
the Both mode, what
we will go into
is that what kind
of security style
do you want on the volume?
Because you, as the owner
of the volume, have to pick
is it NTFS, or is it
Unix style security?
How are the underlying
ACLs actually managed?
And that differs between how
you do file sharing between Unix
and Windows.
So we're going to
give users the control
to be able to specify that,
as well as, to Jonsi's point,
link up to an AD server that
says, OK, this is how my name--
names are being
managed and stuff.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you expose an
endpoint for a certain--
JONSI STEFANSSON: An API?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALIM KARIM: We thought that
would be the first question.
JONSI STEFANSSON:
Yeah, absolutely.
So I mean, like I said,
everything in the UI
is stateless, so it's
actually an API call.
So this is something that
Google and NetApp have actually
built together.
And we're going to
expose that next month.
That's the plan.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Uh-oh.
Don't quote us on that.
JONSI STEFANSSON:
Quote us on it.
That's pressure.
But yeah, so I mean, we have--
we've also been, for example,
doing our Terraform.
For example, scripting so it
actually supports Terraform.
So if you want to automatically
provision everything
with this, or any configuration
management tool, perfect, yeah.
Absolutely.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah,
the end goal here
is there's been so
much work to get
these UIs integrated together
from the UI control pane
perspective, but as a
developer, many don't go to UIs.
So you'd like to
use a CL on the API,
and that's the direction
we're eventually heading.
ALIM KARIM: And many of the--
even the modifications
that we talked about
and how you can go and edit
these volumes, so changing
service levels, for example,
it's hard to say, OK, on Friday
night, I'm going to
go log into the UI
and then change it from extreme
to premium or vice versa.
These are things that exactly
you would script and put
as part of as a business
process for a batch
run or a seasonal update
or whatever it is.
SPEAKER: Please go to the
microphone to ask questions.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Oh,
go to the microphone
if you guys have questions.
ALIM KARIM: It's too late now.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Or just speak
up, and we can reiterate.
ALIM KARIM: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: On actual access
to the UI in a service,
is that based on your GCP
credentials [INAUDIBLE]??
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Correct.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yes, so we're
basically completely mapping
the use of topology of GCP.
So projects, how you share,
what policies you put in place
actually you gets
adopted in here.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Again, if
you're used to logging it,
use Cloud SQL, right.
The intent here is to have
no different experience.
So you log in to Cloud
Console, username and password,
fire up the service, and you
should be able to operate it.
ALIM KARIM: And
we've differentiated
it a little bit in terms
of the discovery piece,
so you need to be a project
owner to enable the service.
Because now you're
talking about something
that's a billable thing.
So you need to be an
owner to enable it,
but once you have
done that, then it's
like editors in the
project have access
to be able to go create it.
We do have some thoughts
around how we introduced
more granular IAM, like
down to create, update,
delete-type permissions,
but that's something
that we introduce later on.
AUDIENCE: So is this a physical
filer sitting in a data center
somewhere, or is it virtual?
ALIM KARIM: Yeah, so right
now it's a physical filer.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
DEVIN LEHMAN: Is this
a physical filer,
or is it sitting somewhere
in a data center--
or, sorry, in the pod.
JONSI STEFANSSON: So I mean,
the software aspect is--
we have multiple service
levels, and service level
might, for example,
be-- the lower service
level might be pure software.
And then premium-- if you want
to rate select, for example,
with genome sequencing,
we had an amazing company
as one of our private
preview customers
that really needed
high-performance storage
to do genome sequencing.
So we would never have been able
to meet that on pure software.
So I think the top tiers are
always going to be hardware.
ALIM KARIM: I think the
way we want it extract
is away from customers, is give
them an SLO-based endpoint,
and then it's up
to us with Google
to engineer the data
plane to meet that SLO.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was just
thinking, OK, there's a globe.
How many physical filers
are in proximity with SMP,
and when do I potentially
run out of demand?
ALIM KARIM: That's
up to us to manage.
And hence it being
a cloud service--
AUDIENCE: None of your business.
[LAUGHTER]
ALIM KARIM: Yeah,
we want customers
to focus on the endpoint and
the SLO of that endpoint,
and leave it to us to
worry about-- or have
sleepless nights.
AUDIENCE: If you've
got 7 petabytes,
maybe you should call.
ALIM KARIM: We'll have to
put something in the UI
that says, you know, too
many zeros, dial this number.
AUDIENCE: Two questions,
first one on the two tiers
that you have.
ALIM KARIM: Three, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I saw the space--
a factor of space there.
So are you saying
it's a scale measure--
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah.
Yeah, so for example, if you
provision a 10 terabyte volume,
you're actually getting 10 times
128, so 1.2 gigabytes a second.
So we've actually
been able to live up
to that, which is
awesome, and we actually
have a customer here that
actually reached higher
than that.
But we sort of flatten out
around 12 to 14 terabytes.
That's when-- it doesn't
scale endlessly, of course,
but that's where we're
sort of capping out.
It's linear until that point,
and then it fattens out.
AUDIENCE: Second
question was around,
when you simply announced Google
Cloud Firestore, [INAUDIBLE]
have here, so how
do you sort of see
those two things shaping up?
JONSI STEFANSSON: Devin,
you want to take that?
You're from Google.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
ALIM KARIM: Let the
Google man answer this.
DEVIN LEHMAN: OK, so
yeah, we can all kind of
take a stab at this
one, but the usage
coming from those
particular users,
so people who are
using NetApp aren't
all of a sudden going to jump
ship and use a completely
different filer technology.
LookSee's a great
example of that.
They've been very,
very awesome in being
co-announcers of our particular
partnership in general.
They're using ONTAP solution,
and they're very excited
a GCP solution as well.
For particular new
users, maybe SMB markets,
or those who are going
through a startup phase, that
aren't going to drop a bunch
of gear and a particular data
center might use
Filestore, but there's
a yin and yang from
which solutions
you're probably going
to end up using.
ALIM KARIM: And that's, from a
customer perspective, you know,
we've had that question come
up, and customers have kind of
given us an answer, which is
for basic needs, yeah, NFS, V3,
whatever filestore is OK.
But as soon as you start
talking about a service that
is more feature-oriented, like
this one, where you can change
service levels, you can have
advanced data management
features, you can have
true multi-protocol
from a single volume.
These are kind of things where--
earlier when I talked about the
customer context, and customers
wanting to move applications
that were file-base,
POSIX-based, to the
cloud, these are the kind
of services that they need.
If it was just about
providing a simple NFS share,
you stand up a single-node
file server and you have that.
You don't even need a service.
You need a service when it
gets into the enterprise
with these kind of features.
But Mavinder, you can--
MAVINDER SINGH: Well, you
kind of stole my thunder,
but from our point
of view at Google,
I think this is all
about customer choice,
so having multiple
services with some features
being available in a
particular service.
It helps customers, and that's
what we're working towards.
Today if you're looking
for, for example, SMB,
you can do that
with Filestore, you
can do that with Cloud Volumes.
To give you an
example, if you're
looking for a non-SQL
database, there
are multiple non-SQL
database options
that are available
to our customers,
and so in the
similar vein, we're
working on both the
offerings for our customers.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Good questions.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Cool.
ALIM KARIM: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: How does
the pricing forecast?
Sounds like in the demo you're
able to toggle those three
options.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALIM KARIM: So something
the product manager
should have covered earlier.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Where is he?
Oh, he's here?
ALIM KARIM: Yeah, so
the pricing is actually
separate for each of
the service tiers.
And how we do this is based
on allocated capacity,
but the-- call it the skew--
is changeable.
So if you allocate
5 terabytes today
of Premium, and in one week
you change that to be Extreme,
we track the skew with
Google in the back end.
So the billing engine
will bill you one week's
worth of usage on
Premium, and then
one week's worth of
usage on Extreme,
or whatever your
capacity ends up being.
So the flexibility is mirrored
by the underlying economics.
AUDIENCE: I see, so you commit
to that month, but it skews it.
ALIM KARIM: Yeah, so it's--
right.
So it's true pay-go in
the sense that if you
start with 5
terabytes of Premium,
you can change that to
5 terabytes of Extreme
in the middle of the month.
So if Premium is $0.30 a gig,
and Extreme is $0.40 a gig,
it will be the average of those
two is what you're going to pay
at the end of the month.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALIM KARIM: Which storage media?
Something that gives you
either 16, 64, or 128 megabytes
per terabyte stored.
AUDIENCE: Still none
of your business.
[LAUGHTER]
ALIM KARIM: Again, focus
on the performance SLO.
AUDIENCE: Can you shed
light on projects?
ALIM KARIM: No,
not at the moment.
And we wanted to keep this
consistent with how GCP does
resource management.
And that's been-- to Jonsi's
earlier point, the core design
principle.
Keep it like a resource
within a project that's
isolated within a project.
And we haven't really come
up with any kind of use cases
or customer information that
said across-project sharing is
needed.
I don't know.
Jonsi, you want to add to that?
JONSI STEFANSSON:
Yeah, actually this
is something that we
really want to look into.
Because let's say you have
your development team that
is actually developing, and
then they want to push it,
and they want to take advantage
of being able to clone a volume
that's going from development,
to staging, and then
to production, and that might
be totally different project.
So I really understand--
as a developer, I
really understand
the flow should really
be there, and that's
what we're really looking into.
I'm really glad you asked that
question, because I've actually
been fighting to actually
get it implemented.
So I really get the
use case for that.
AUDIENCE: When you're using
the word "project," are
you talking about XPN and those
projects or service projects?
Are you limiting it
to a specific network?
ALIM KARIM: Right.
Good question.
So the question was that is
this an XPN shared project?
In Google, you have the ability
to create a parent project,
and then child
projects underneath,
with shared resources,
firewall rules, and such.
So right now, we're talking
about a flat topology.
So it's the services
available within the project
that you provision in that.
The ability to do
cross-project networking
and actually have a hierarchy
of projects, that's something
we're going to introduce later.
There's really-- there's
some technical things,
but mostly it's just testing
and QA'ing that setup,
and making sure it works.
So at the moment, think about
it as a flat in-project--
in-the-same-project resource.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALIM KARIM: Yeah.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah.
ALIM KARIM: More for
testing things, like I said.
AUDIENCE: So how will
you handle some use cases
where they need the performance
but not the capacity?
ALIM KARIM: They
need the performance
but they don't
need the capacity?
So then-- my answer, and
then I'm sure Jonsi has his,
but my answer is that when
you're procuring a cloud
volume, you're actually
paying for a resource that
has two dimensions.
You have a capacity dimension
and a performance dimension.
And you're going to pay
for what you need the most.
So if you need capacity, you're
going to pay for capacity.
If you need performance, you're
going to over-allocate capacity
in order to get the
performance you need.
That's why we also have
service tiers to be
able to be a little bit
more flexible with that,
and not so rigid,
but in some cases,
you're going to have
to over-provision.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah, I mean,
we were really, really lucky
when it came to private
preview customers.
We basically got every
single flavor of workload,
so we could actually
work really closely
with all those customers.
One of them was running
Oracle databases on file,
and they've always been running
that on block, for example.
But they were
actually clustering it
so it was multi-host-attached,
so they are actually
getting way better performance
or throughput on flash.
We saw that they were
over-provisioning.
Even though the database
might have been, like,
a terabyte, almost
all of them, they
were provisioning 10, 12,
14 terabytes to actually get
the performance.
So to your point, what
was the biggest value
for them was actually
finally they actually
could run those Oracle
workloads in the public load.
And they hadn't been able to do
that until with Cloud Volumes.
So it was actually--
you can see that
you're paying for way
more capacity than you're
actually using, but--
ALIM KARIM: Sometimes you
have to pay for what you need,
I guess.
In this case, you
need performance.
DEVIN LEHMAN: I'd like just to
highlight that really quickly,
too.
So working with NetApp in
this particular partnership
has been instrumental
in getting projects
like this off the ground.
So their customers are
fantastic with feedback.
Their customers are fantastic
in saying what doesn't work
and what does work.
And the antithesis of
that is what you're
seeing on the screen today.
ALIM KARIM: There
was another question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONSI STEFANSSON: No.
So we already have, like
in our staging environment
with Google, we already
have Cloud Sync.
We're with the Cloud Sync.
That actually can synchronize
from endpoint to endpoint
and is agnostic when
it comes to filers.
If you're asking about something
like Snap Mirror or something
that's actually retaining
[INAUDIBLE] duplication
and compression
during transfer--
AUDIENCE: It's not the same.
JONSI STEFANSSON: No,
it's not, but I mean,
that's something that we
are really looking into.
But the thing is it's actually
a single-tenant environment,
a cluster-wide variable that is
being pushed to a multi-tenant,
and Google would just
say, are you guys crazy?
You're not-- this would be
a breach of all security
protocols, basically, because
you're taking something
from a single-tenant, and the
way it's actually required.
But NetApp and Google,
we are actually
working on reducing
the granularity of that
so you can actually set
it on a volume level.
And if that's the case, then
we can introduce Snap Mirror.
Probably revealing
something that I'm not
allowed to, like always, but--
[LAUGHTER]
ALIM KARIM: Sure, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: When you tier your
different service levels,
is it actually
migrating the volumes,
or is it just [INAUDIBLE]?
JONSI STEFANSSON:
So yeah, that's
actually a great question.
So we have a scheduler that
is running that is actually
monitoring if the
controller is congested,
if it can actually handle
changing the service level.
If it's congested or can't
handle those 128 megabytes
a second, it's moved,
and we take care
of that with the scheduler.
So everything is automatic.
It happens automatically.
AUDIENCE: It's per second,
so the data rate, you're
going by seconds as well?
ALIM KARIM: Yes, so our
billing granularity rate now
is per hour.
So we monitor capacity
within a given hour.
We have multiple data
points within the hour
that we average
out, but the idea
is to make it even
more granular.
But we figured,
at least to start
with, with the pay-go
option, we'll do hourly.
The monitoring, it will be--
or billing metrics every hour.
AUDIENCE: So you keep
saying pay-go options.
What other options are--
ALIM KARIM: Right, yeah.
Good question.
So pay-go basically
is where we want it
to start, like a cloud service.
But what we want
to introduce also
is this notion of being
able to do subscriptions.
And you can use a different
term, but essentially
customers that want to commit
for a volume of capacity
for a given duration, you
get a certain discount.
What those things
are, we're still
working through, and
trying to figure out
what the sweet spots
are, in terms of, is it
100 terabytes for 12 months, or
is it a petabyte for 12 months,
and we're going to
introduce those.
There's always going to
be sort of edge cases,
but we do want to have
some standard subscription
options directly
in the cloud that
said that you have to
use this much capacity,
and you're committing to use
it for this amount of time.
You will get billed
monthly, but in exchange
for that term in volume, you're
going to get a discount of X%.
JONSI STEFANSSON: We
will just, like, bundle--
like petabyte bundle.
That's actually been one
of the feature requests
from our private preview
customers is actually
to introduce that as well.
AUDIENCE: Is there
Stackdriver [INAUDIBLE]??
ALIM KARIM: That's
a Devin question.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yes, it is.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
DEVIN LEHMAN: Is it
integrated with Stackdriver
for monitoring so you can do
your reporting and everything?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do customers ever
engage NetApp for support?
ALIM KARIM: Not directly.
So the way the
support workflow works
is that the customer
contacts Google.
Google does basically
L1 to L2 support,
and if there are issues with
whatever the infrastructure is,
or whatever the software is
running in the background,
those issues are escalated
between NetApp and Google.
NetApp may get pulled in
to solve certain customer
problems, but it's always
Google owning the support
relationship.
There may be a NetApp
person there to help solve,
but Google and the
customer are where
the support endpoints are.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah,
that's one of the things
that we really
wanted to emphasize.
You have a single billing, you
have a single support contact,
you have a single contact for
everything, and that's Google.
So it should be--
we wanted to have
it as integrated
in all areas as possible.
So it's been really good.
And it's been a
fantastic journey.
I mean, we've been like
these code sessions--
code jam sessions with
Google and NetApp.
So I mean, it's been
a true partnership,
and we're actually really
proud of what it resulted in.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah, just to
reiterate that from the Google
side, it really
is a joint effort
to get something like this
up and running, especially
this holistically integrated.
And as Alim was saying,
from a user perspective,
you should be able to
come in as a GCP user,
never standing up ONTAP
and totally understand
the experience.
And vice versa, going into
ONTAP, never going into GCP,
firing it up and having
a great experience.
AUDIENCE: How long
did the project
take to get to this point?
DEVIN LEHMAN: That's
a great question.
ALIM KARIM: Not as long
as you would think.
DEVIN LEHMAN: Yeah.
Good answer.
[LAUGHTER]
JONSI STEFANSSON: Does that
mean you're not answering?
DEVIN LEHMAN: No, the
product manager just
said it right there.
AUDIENCE: It's ONTAP
in the cloud in 2014.
[CHUCKLING]
So we've been at
this for a while.
This version of
it is more recent,
but we've done all sorts
of things for a long time.
ALIM KARIM: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you change
your capacity on the fly?
JONSI STEFANSSON: Yeah.
ALIM KARIM: Yep, that allocated
capacity is a flexible number.
You can change it
any time you want.
JONSI STEFANSSON: It is
actually like a soft quota.
So it's not like a hard limit.
You can actually go above it,
and we'll actually pick it up
in the billing.
So you can actually,
if in some weird cases
you don't want the performance,
and you allocated a terabyte,
and you can shoot over that.
It's a soft quota.
So it's not-- like, if
you're running a database,
you don't want it to stall
or corrupt the database.
You want it to be
able to scale up.
So it's a soft quota,
and it's more for you
to manage and get the expected
performance out of that
DEVIN LEHMAN: As
Jonsi was talking,
I just did that for you.
So that was going on
in the background.
ALIM KARIM: And
again, as I mentioned,
this is monitored every hour
from a billing perspective.
So if you change the capacity
halfway through the month,
it's only halfway
through the month
that you're billed for
the higher capacity.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: In which regions?
ALIM KARIM: Ah, I was wondering
when that would come up.
So regions, we're
starting in US east 4,
and our plan is that
by the end of the year,
we'll be live in US central 1,
as well as Europe West 3, which
is Frankfurt.
And then we will be
adding other regions
in the US in 2019 on
the west coast as well.
JONSI STEFANSSON: And when--
if you go to Create Volume,
I don't know if you guys
saw that you can actually
have like a region switcher.
So you can actually--
if you had subscribed to Cloud
Volume in multiple regions,
we would basically
just select here
where you want to provision.
AUDIENCE: How are you
handling the regional, just
[INAUDIBLE] solutions
with that [INAUDIBLE]??
ALIM KARIM: So
right now these are
availabilities within a
region, accessible to all zones
within a region,
available within a region,
but we're not our
cross-region yet.
It's something that we have
on the roadmap, the ability
to be able to have a cloud
volume in one region replicated
to a cloud volume
in another region.
That's something that we're
going to bring later on,
but it's not there right now.
JONSI STEFANSSON: And
you can go into the SLAs,
the up-times and
everything that we are--
that's your job, man.
[LAUGHTER]
ALIM KARIM: You already started.
Go ahead.
JONSI STEFANSSON: No.
Dude.
OK.
I think it's six
nines durability.
Yeah.
So but it's tied
to-- within a region.
So like Alim said, ONTAP
already has all these features.
We are basically just
slowly integrating it
into GCP, or into
the Cloud Volumes.
So you have, like,
cross-site replication
built in into
ONTAP, it's just how
you are actually doing that
on a multi-tenant level.
So we're looking
into all of that.
ALIM KARIM: And
basically, there's
going to be additional
things we add,
but really when we
talk to customers,
as I said in the
beginning, it was just
this core notion of having
an NFS or SMB endpoint
with these features was
really where they were stuck
in terms of being able
to either deploy or move
new applications.
That's why this has kind
of been our super-focus
for the initial payload,
and then the add-ons
will come over time.
JONSI STEFANSSON:
And I actually think
it says a lot about the
rate of development,
because when we started, when
the first private preview
customers came in, they
only got the [INAUDIBLE]..
Then we introduced On-Demand
Snapshots, Snapshot Policy,
Export Policy,
then Cloud Sync is
coming, even Cloud Backup is
coming, where you can actually
back up data from Cloud Volumes
to the Google Optic Storage.
So the rate of development
has been really, really fast,
and the features that we
have been introducing.
And it was kind of
funny, because many
of our private
preview customers,
they were like, OK, NetApp
is a real cloud company now
because they all of a sudden
saw features just popping up
within the Google console.
So it's-- yeah, its been--
and we are nowhere stopping.
We are going to continue
with the innovation,
and the partnership,
and yeah, it's good.
ALIM KARIM: So we kept it
to four slides, or five.
You want to go
another slide, or--
[SIGHING]
JONSI STEFANSSON: No.
ALIM KARIM: But, and
I think, actually,
having this interactive
session, and having
you guys ask the
questions, these really
were what the rest of the
sides were about-- what
regions, how do I get
billed, how do I do this,
how do I do that.
So I think we're almost
out of time, but at least
from my perspective,
to Jonsi's point,
the partnership goes beyond--
we're standing here doing
this because of a broad team
at NetApp and Google
that supports us,
our business development team,
[? Lynam ?] and [? Vindor, ?]
our engineering team-- hats off
to these guys for pulling this
off, operations teams that
integrate with support.
So all around, it's been
a fantastic partnership
to get us to where
we are, and we're
really excited on what
this can do for customers.
That's all we had.
Thank you.
JONSI STEFANSSON: Thank.
You
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]